jean-luc d'ailleurs quelle image tu as
marqué alors moi je crois que c'est
l'info on a fait de l'hypnose sur le
plateau il y avait il ya dubertrand
chamerois et je vais aussi mathieu qui
était très réceptif
alors les gens ils étaient bons à sétif
qui le christ était truqué mais je peux
le dire une nouvelle fois ce n'était pas
truqué parce que moi je rappelle qu'en
coulisses j'ai récupéré gilles et
bertrand chamerois qui était vraiment
pas bien
et le moment où mathieu voulu faire un
saïfi sais rien ce temps-là majeur on a
fait rentrer un lan sur le plateau et
l'hypnotiseur leur a fait croire que
c'était rihanna et vous allez voir qu'en
lan rendre sur le plateau
les trois sont persuadés que c'est
rihanna y voit rihanna il ne voit pas là
ne voit rien à ces énormes
regardez ça c'est un des plus grands
moments de tpm p j'avoue jean-luc je
m'en rappelle très bien aussi c'est
parti rihanna est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
rihanna comme elle est belle
elana
[Musique]
m
les séries et vous avez reconnu et
djezzy au nom avec désiré là c'est vrai
ce que vous allez chanter une petite
chanson assez au soleil
malgré la timide et my way est ce que
vous avez
qu'est ce que vous en avez dû dire à
rihanna c'est le moment ce qu'elle va
faire un live
[Rires]
oui
notre erreur
si ces partis laïques de rihanna
l'ars
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous
c'est à dire jeter un regard songeur
avant que c'était patrick et thierry tu
étais là aussi oui c'est pas truqué
parce que il ya une autre séquence où on
avait dit à bertrand de ne pas prononcer
les eaux dans sa chronique séoul était à
côté un quart d'heure avant en train de
barétous les hôtes sac fiche de ses
chroniques
il était complètement les petits c
lagarde géraldine parents vous qui
n'étaient pas dans l'émission ce que
vous y avez cru devant votre poste
ou est ce qu'en fait non franchement non
je vous jure c'est non géraldine mois
pour connaître un peu de gym avoir connu
à la radio grâce à vous je me suis dit
que c'était possible parce que j'ai des
très sensibles à ça et je pense que
c'est pas quelqu'un qui keaton ou qui
est dans un truc de jeu de comédie donc
je croyais avant la bouder qui nous a
rejoint boudé à ce que tu as cru toi ben
frej fois mais ça pas de cap a touché
ses oreilles à un moment donné à paris
n'était pas rihanna parce qu'ils sont
donne un truc c'est incroyable